in taste of 25th of September all right
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcasts
from Monday
they say podcast podcasts for Monday
September 25th 2017 what's going on how
are you what's up I am back from Toronto
Canada and every once in a while every
once in a long while I have a I have a
guest and I always get good guests and
this is no today is no exception we have
the great Felipe Esparza on here who has
a welcome first of all welcome they've
had me was so fool there you go Felipe
Esparza from the what's up pool podcast
and let's get all the hype out of the
way at first we got you have a new HBO
special yes a new HBO special on
September 30 at 10:00 September 30th at
10:00 on HBO that's where the HBO
specials are called translate this so
let's get into it
tell me about that wasn't like to shoot
a hour-long special for HBO it was it
was good
I started myself I I am I got the money
together I stayed up to money and my
wife and I we we chose San Jose improv
and we got cloud shires uh-huh and it
was all DIY you know so you did it
yourself an HBO liked it so much they
bought it oh so when you were doing it
you weren't thinking like holy [ __ ] I'm
doing an HBO special don't know where
it's gonna go they open go to Netflix
that work Amazon no but that's I think
that's a that's a great waited now how
the [ __ ] is nobody giving you a shot I
don't know you know why you're not white
like me I gotta be honest before we I
did this you know I always look up like
videos and all that type of stuff to
make sure I got something to talk about
so it doesn't become this like my
biggest fear with these interviews is
it's just gonna become this horrific
staring contest because I'm such a huge
fan of what you do and I had never seen
the the Ari Shaffir when Ari Shaffir was
hosting the show this isn't happening
yeah when you told that whole story
about being in the gang and fighting the
guy biting his ear off and Shea's just
like like I was listening to that that
story it was like this is like at least
three different Terran
Teno movies huh and then he you ended it
in just such a nice place I don't want
to force you to tell the story again but
if you could just recap my um start bite
where did you grow up I grew up in um
Boyle Heights California you know Los
Angeles but East LA but come Boyle
Heights you know East LA is like further
east East and Los Angeles you know it's
by almost close to Monterey Park but
Boyle Heights in the neighborhood how
far away is that to put it in white
perspective how far away is that from
the Staples Center
ooh if I were to walk they'll take me
like an hour and now if you were to
drive probably 50 minutes within minutes
okay cool a 30 minute bus ride
okay 30 minute bus ride so you grew up
what you what what decade you're a child
of what you katie's you're the age I
grew up in the 80s so that was the real
deal yeah I grew up my neighborhood was
in the housing projects mm-hmm Pico
Gardens and there was like three
separate housing project was a little
village Pico Ali so and then Pico
Gardens from first Street to like sixth
Street okay
and it was like [ __ ] man you like a
shitload of gangs like maybe 11 how did
you know when you're not in a gang and
you're a young kid how do you negotiate
like I gotta get from my house I gotta
go pick up my [ __ ] I gotta go do my
laundry I got to go to school how do you
negotiate is it now a gangs 24/7 oh yeah
man they're 25 neighborhood they were
24/7 yeah I I always thought they came
out around 5:00 like anybody with like
just living the regular lifestyle goes
to bed and then they just kind of give
up this the area there and then those
gangs they come on at 5:00 they're like
the gang that they are still living in a
gentrified neighborhood okay don't come
on a date ugh they might call the cops
on them oh yeah man but most gangs you
know from Echo Park they come out at
night man robbing people really yeah
they come out at night
those guys were where were their
justification those gangs are still
around but they come on at night and a
gangbanger different areas you know but
there's still gangbang you know it'll
happen
how old were you the first time you got
mugged
I got mugged on the first time when I
was like 18 years old my friend I'm Coco
that's pretty good man yeah I got
another 18 Downtown Crossing when I was
like in eighth grade then I was like I
was selling crack on my first day like
that
within one hour I got robbed somebody
put a knife behind my back another knife
in might like in front of me and they
took all my my crack away took all you
crack away so yeah then what do you have
to do I had to go back to the guy who
gave it to me our friend of mine who I
grew up with you know he passed away
already used to call him Coco uh-huh and
we grew up together him and I where I'm
from second grade two adults I needed
money at the time I got somebody
pregnant and I didn't know how to make
money so I asked him for a job in the
criminal business okay you know how does
that go down you probably have I no
avoid it it's like I don't want to sell
drugs but I kind of have to now I got a
kid coming so help me so he gave me like
a hundred dollars of crack you know a
hundred meters just bring me back a
hundred then I give you more to sell so
I suggest I got out didn't know who I
was in that neighborhood they just came
around me and he took all my stuff then
he hurt me or anything I was begging for
my just gonna keep my ID and he gave my
ID I like did how scared we I was scared
my I thought they were gonna kill me
right there I was I felt like I was
young I was really scared but I'll calm
you know I wasn't like uh-uh all right
just take him and just take you leave me
alone
you know I just walked out I take it I
didn't fight him or nothing because I
know they would have killed me or stab
me and worse so went back to my friend
Coco and I told him what happened and
and I thought you know he was gonna be
okay man you know it's all right your
happens happens no man that night
escalated like it took with it he gave
you the crack and I go honey
midnight I got robbed about 1:30 at 2:30
in the morning I'm back at his house
what who robbed your cars so what
happened he gave me a gun he gave me him
since though right he got himself a
pistol and he put on a blue handkerchief
on his on his head
and he put a black beanie on and we both
went looking for a little guys and you
must have been praying to God like I
don't want to murder somebody the first
oh hell yeah I'm out pray please don't
find those guys Wow
because right there I was like I would
probably was done anything he would have
told me I was vulnerable I was weak
right you know I have no I don't know
what to do so we went together and we
saw one guy that saw what happened but
he didn't do anything and and then like
he kind of like hit him real hard and
who did it man
well yet then I said man he wasn't here
man within him so they wasn't him wait
how did Danny so you hold this I
remember that guy standing there
watching me get robbed so now this poor
bastard gets dragged into it
he gets dragged into it he got like he
got a gun slap you know by my friend
he's my friend leaving that's a little
question he just hit him in the face
hard man and like it started be familiar
and I just say wow man he was look at
every like come on man please tell him
it wasn't me so you waited till after
the pistol slap
I meant meant to Titus it wasn't him so
we got lovely happened to him and we
went back and later on those guys who
actually did it walk back and gave it
back or everything get back to crack to
that guy and everything was cool that's
what he has there sorry we don't know
that they were afraid of that guy yes
sir we don't know Batman were with you
yeah we should Street nickname yeah so
then after that then they knew that you
were with him so then people stop
[ __ ] with you people thought messing
with me yeah Jesus Christ this is what
kills me about you is you have like a
thousand of those stories and you're the
most relaxed laid-back guy ever like
where did it all go cuz dude I look at
me I I sound like I lived your life and
you sound like you lived my life like
you sound like you grew up in a nice
little cul-de-sac area and played street
hockey and I'm all [ __ ] wound up how
did you do that well I have a mama I
have parents I had my mom and dad and
most of my crazy friends in the projects
you know the crazier ones didn't have a
mom and dad all right they had nobody
telling him you better come home early
or there was nobody telling those kids
to come home and the lights go on in the
streets so they had no really nobody
telling them what to do how to live
right
no discipline I have my mom and dad my
dad worked and my mom stood on my work
that uh elementary school where they're
like be home from selling crack when the
street lights came on right yeah oh is
that Family Foundation but I've always
but I don't get that I just now you're
talking at our home life but you're
telling you you're doing all this other
[ __ ] no the kid you know when I was like
13 12 14 years old I wasn't crazy oh I
got crazy after high school I got
someone pregnant didn't know what to do
but I was always like a little hustler
man my mom who saw Avon and I would
collect the money for her uh-huh you
know so I learned how to collect money
for people at least for my mom was
always telling her Herbalife Avon
she was only selling something so we
live by the warehouses in downtown LA
where the factories are at where other
trucks would come in and pick up stuff
on the trains and take him to like
stores so my mom knew were like we used
to go to his one factory and we wished
to UM put a bunch of that synthetic
cotton the plastic one they would throw
it away my mom and I were put in bags
like hefty bags mm-hmm and then we go to
another place where they would throw
with these raggedy old sheets and then
my mom was so those raggedy old sheets
with the cotton and then Woodward
Oradell door the door in a housing
project styling pillows so you guys were
a real green family man you were there
you were there recycling that see we saw
before the trash and we slowly like we
saw pillows I used to when I was like 14
I used to walk to downtown to do with
pallets would you build a little house
and then sell that no man that that's
too much work I want we want fast money
oh okay ash other was a bunch of
factories where I live you know I felt
like I felt like Henry Hiro from
Goodfellas right because they were
always stealing stuff from the airport
and we were always taking stuff from
these factories
I wasn't stealing from his factories my
friends were I was taking stuff on the
trash like um no there was a watermelon
factory and they will throw away rotten
watermelons and I will get the
watermelons and clever man
so watermelon like they make water like
that you know they grew them know that
they will get them from the farm we're
against Andy right they would hold them
there they have pallets full of
watermelon from because there's like a
grocery area of downtown LA where every
grocer out gets all this other stuff
flowers stereos you know you name it
piñatas I don't know where everything is
that suits the cheap suits I know where
things that so we'll get the one hang
out and just go to the dumpsters and
whenever they threw out you would then
go sell yeah I will cut that watermelon
in half and then go sell it to those
Mexicans day laborers everybody that
working in the factories much a bunch of
immigrants right and I saw the half a
watermelon for a dollar two dollars five
I would just cut the rotted piece off
you know I mean oh it wants to know why
nobody's looking I was saying my little
home girl this girl this little less
well she's a lesbian now but we don't
know she was a lesbian now she was a
tomboy right I was sent her in there
with my brother they were there was like
when they were nobody was looking they
would throw good water man in a trash
can - so we don't make sure of good and
bad water - how long did you stay in
that whole world is selling crack and
all of that and all those fights and
biting the guy's ear off and all that
[ __ ] before you became a comedian like
how long how long was that period you
like that was my period from 18 years
old to like 21 and a half 21 and a half
because that 21 is when I was like
messing up already man I was like I'm
smoking a lot of PCP I was like my drug
of choice for the time being and when I
have to get awkward CPC pee like I think
is a elephant tranquilizer
that's what people tell me I saw you say
that grown up PCP angel dust and all and
yeah angel angel dust is like come and
crystallized PCP you could put in a
cigarette but PCP in my neighborhood we
were at the PCP capital of Los Angeles
like in my neighborhood they sold
gallons of it people had to they
wouldn't have I'm sparklers water full
of PCP so everybody had PCP wait a
minute you could hide you ingested you
smoked it no you did a girl
I'm giving away secrets here I'm not I
don't know
I'll tell you I'm asking cuz everybody
tries to act like you understand all no
ma'am I'm a boozehound but I don't know
any that stuff you will get a newport
cigarette every a menthol cigarette a
Newport and then you put you or you and
you dip it instead it a little jar like
um just a tip and that's a $5 tip that's
a $5 dip you dip it again at ten you dip
a whole one is twenty you know you you
soak it as $30 and it's by tip you know
now I get it that's like when I drink
booze there's like the ten-year-old [ __ ]
that you're Ollie up to 25 then you get
into the cognac sand they can be like I
don't know like a fun I don't wines and
[ __ ] could be like a century or old or
something so there's one night I'm
smoking PCP playing it just because I'm
stupid as hell when it comes to it so
what is it what's that hi like oh man
it's like you're doing credible Hulk if
somebody attacks you oh this is this
[ __ ] when like five cops show up and
they got five more did you see that
Chuck Bronson movie this was three when
one white boy like the surfer he's been
he's fighting all the police officers
he's on PCP okay I got a rewatch that
yeah I'm a PCB King you think you have
um like incredible hole strength but you
just have like more you don't feel pain
but while people are hitting you man you
could just keep attacking forever you
know what I mean right and then the next
morning you wake up and you feel like
you played 12 years in the NFL yeah man
alright so the first time you smoked PCP
and that [ __ ] hits you it's like
literally like you're turning into like
a superhero yeah man well the one time
what did you do did you try to bend
something that's what cops now know I
want to try to pull something off the
[ __ ] wall
I've been together ona well when I was
like walking around I was becoming to be
known as Batman you know he's crazy
watch out for him why did they call you
why did they call you Batman cuz um I
love Batman a nice to wear my nose I'm
the superhero on the rules uh-huh and 18
yeah - well the Batman shirts still fit
so I wore it and I don't know where to
get a Batman shirt anywhere else was the
underoos factory right down the street
out of the dump
- the bad projects yeah that's amazing
alright so you're doing all that I'm
watching um I'm at the drive-in theater
with my friends smoking PCP watching
Terminator 2 asking why I'm saying I'd
fight that guy yeah man and I'm thinking
about the guy that had bullied me for
the last two weeks so I'll go wait if
you smoked that say say a guy view is I
shouldn't do this because I'm not doing
a commercial here for the drug saying
there's somebody bullying you you can't
beat that guy right if you were to smoke
some PCP it definitely would give you
the belief but can it overcome how slow
you are on your inability to slip a
punch and all you just walk through his
[ __ ]
yeah man you're throwing punches because
um when I when I got into a fight with
this guy I was they told me I was doing
things that I remember doing I think
they told me that took my belt off and
I'm whipping them all over though right
you got it we keep alluding to the story
you gotta tell the story right so you're
Batman you got on your underoos you
smoked PCP at the drive-in
you saw the Terminator - when I left the
Terminator - movie I come back in a
project and I see this guy that he's
late he's like an old dude man he's like
30 years old he just came out of prison
you don't know who I am
he's like calling me bad names and
pushing me and pushing me and I'm gonna
fight him pushing me like finally I
socked him in the face but I kind of
missed then he hit me right in the eye
and he hit me hard and I got black right
away he punched me in the face I started
bleeding
they started choking me so when I
started choking me that's when I like
got why we're crazy I went crazy man I
lifted him up dropped him Billy I bit
his ear off first of all turned into the
home a bit easier up I would like the
whole Kobe to retire brother let me ask
you this when you paid his ear off we
were underneath are you on top of him
how would I underneath him he was
choking me and you just all of a sudden
that pcp can't get it off man I never
thought my skin is so low easy to bite
off and yeah well I spin crochet I just
no not even man I spit it out and it's
like punching him and then my friends
told me that uh wait what did he do
oh man took the hits like a soldier so
when you Benazir off this guy's heel
he's he's screaming like a little girl
okay do the pain so actually he's kind
of screaming like a guy who got his ear
better off yeah at that point I think
you're still a man if you if you go up a
few octaves when you're missing a
[ __ ] hear but I don't know why I bit
his ear up mean I had no I guess I had
no choice you know he was choking me
sounded like that was the move no one
was helping me he wasn't didn't seem
like he was gonna be stopping alright
see you beat it yeah then you took your
belt off and you were my friends told me
that I took it my belt off and I started
whipping him like he was like chasing
them with a belt whipping them that guy
like he was let go runaway property or
something and how many people are
witnessing this I think that's well 15
people but they're all I cheer me on
cheering here Marv nobody's helping
dynamic hits that would get like
nowadays if they would dude that would
that would be like it would be epic PCP
guy epic belt guy that'd be something
like that I would have been a rap song
auto-tune Batman yeah so wait a minute
so when you so you don't remember doing
that so there was like all [ __ ] this
guy's gonna kill me then you start to
bite his ear I feel like wow ears come
off really easily then you sort of black
out and then like well you just sort of
came to with like blood all over you
going like then I just need a hot dogger
so yeah the next day I wake the next day
I'm walking around it's like 10 a 7:00
in the morning 8:00 in the morning I
don't know man I'm looking at my body
it's full of blood my pants my face you
know my have a black guy my shirt is
full of blood I have no idea what
happened I have no idea what happened
you probably thought it was your blood
yeah why I don't know man I would like
check him Steve got shot or stabbed by
somebody didn't know then my friends
told me what happened and that guy was
in the hot he went to the hospital for
her like a broken ribs among here
missing ear you know what I just put
Neosporin on that house that they went
to it he was laying in bed and they
asked him if do you want to press
charges you know cuz everybody know
there was witnesses
everybody knew who did it and he said no
we're gonna handle it the right way and
I'm like
I didn't even know no this until later
on like a week later yeah man
I think there's like a green light on
you right now and you mean like green
light what do you mean green light yeah
man
shoot to kill they see you what the [ __ ]
so that's the first time you ever heard
that so now well now what do you do
besides not go outside do they know
where you live they know where I live
but I don't know what the he's doing a
hospital though but everything's calm
you know but he's doing a hospital but I
could feel tension from people who or
who I thought were my friend at one time
what who I grew up with you know you
know they were turning on me like cuz I
when they were in their gang I was in
another gang when you watch the wire do
you like fall asleep is it like boring
to you because I watch the wire I think
you don't need to you live in it that's
what I'm saying like it sounds like an
award-winning series to me I'm more like
blood in blood out so wait a minute so
now there's a green light on you
yeah and okay at some point you got to
go outside to get food cuz you're hungry
yeah so I'm good when you have a green
light on you in in East LA what's a good
time to go out if you gotta go hit hit
the mayfair market or whatever what's
wrong man I don't think to go to Dubai
when you know when you have a green
light and enough from anybody you know
whether it comes from prison or if it
comes from just the neighborhood it's
just relieve man move somewhere safe
like Modesto what's a more serious green
light if it came from prisoner from the
neighborhood of a home and if it come
from prison you're a dead man man I mean
there's nowhere to go there's nowhere to
go man and I read about these things you
know outside of it on books there's
nobody coming back from that
but they would like only like a green
light from his neighborhood you know
let's go to the mall know kind of like
the Grove pick a really white mall and
you know what all those thoughts came to
my mind at that time like man I wish I
was like the French Prince of bel-air
rich white guy to take a rich white guy
rich [ __ ] Mexican guy oh no way they
weren't were on that show that was
different strokes those difference drums
beating drumming
they switched it up there like it's
different strokes acceptance right now
yeah that's what they owe with anything
I always do that [ __ ] so my mom called
our father Greg Boyle and he's like this
priest that I grew up with in the
neighborhood he's from the homeboy
industries hearing our name that's a
thing yeah he helps he up some gang
members that's a cool name
well the great Boyle he's like a priest
for my neighborhood and um he's always
helped the neighborhood like he would go
out his way to help people he was like
if he's like me driving and then you
like he will pick up kids that were
drunk off the streets and take him home
he did that a couple of times for me in
a good way in a good way yeah like if
you're a gang member in the wrong
neighborhood and then you know you're
pretty much someone's gonna kill you in
that neighborhood for the great boy will
tell you get in a van I'll take you back
home as a gang member how do you end up
in the wrong neighborhood other than a
woman oh man on PCP
oh they're goddamn PCP there's no heroin
in your neighborhood so let's go buy
heroin somewhere else you know there's
no crack in the neighborhood you know
it's a dry spell somewhere and you gotta
get hive so you gotta go to another
neighborhood and buy it oh oh you have
an aunt so how do they know you're in a
different gang you don't go over there
wearing your whole your colors
oh man though most of the the hardcore
gang members they were the colors man
they never left that wearing their
colors yeah boy they're not undercover
there 24/7 but I wasn't one I wouldn't
want even one of those guys I was
nothing like that I was just a guy who
was just hanging around with these kids
then one day I get jumped into a gang
and I'm getting to oh so much trouble
but I don't know ideas to get beaten
into a gang just in case I ever [ __ ]
my life up and I go to prison you know
or I go to prison my only hope is I
gotta join the Aryan Nazi guy's [ __ ]
and pretend I believe it just to save
myself how long is that beatdown well in
in the streets it would be like I guess
whatever number the gang is of his 18th
Street you gonna get beat up for 18
seconds that's it yeah or but I mean how
many guys all over
oh Jesus okay [ __ ] okay strike think
that's it from the record there because
when I got jumped in I was just hanging
out man like I was just hanging out and
then somebody stay down a man you're
gonna get jumped in and I wasn't gonna
say no if I say no I'm a punk I'm gonna
get jumped in I'm gonna get jail for
being a punk so I said [ __ ] let's do
it
and then I punched the guy next to me
for no reason well because I want to
prove that I'm tough so the guy next to
my just knocked him out with one punch
man
and then I hit like he wasn't even
looking I say let's do this and then
like I hit him back you know you gotta
be ready Big Dawg
look how many that warrants at moma keep
your head on a swivel I better get the
other guy's [ __ ] later okay next time
you gonna jump somebody yet can you not
say it what I'm sitting right next to
you knew he was a lefty what the [ __ ]
yeah you get beat up man and I got
jumped by everybody that dose you get
one in and did you get more than one in
you get one I got two in one him and
another guy but then after that I felt
like Nike cortex all over my face so you
just laying on the ground and you just
going 1 Mississippi 2 we're just waiting
for this rain of footlocker to stop
coming down on you yeah man I was like I
thought they were gonna stop man so what
do you do I would just other funny
things done all right here enough hit
enough then everybody's hugging me the
same people that were beating my brains
up we're hugging me and kiss me you know
I love you you're my boy you're my
family now and I like Wow so then you
come home ok and then you're just
sitting there all right with [ __ ]
sneaker marks all over you and you're
going like ok now I guess I'm in a gang
Jesus Christ okay so then what happens I
thought it what happened was I thought
of hanging wrong you know and white
people talk about white privilege go
dude what the [ __ ] is that this is what
it is totally yes it's it they're
selling lemonade at the end of your
driveway and they accidentally did I
just join a gang there was there's a
green light on you you were selling
lemonade
at the end of the wrong driveway you're
in the wrong neighborhood okay was dumb
but you know like there was two white
boys in my neighborhood that were gangs
was one the redheaded kid from children
of the corn exactly he was he was it
says one guy he was a blood that Malachi
he was from East LA snow man they call
him
okay it was actually two white boy if I
had a fence if by the way but continue
there was two white boys in the hood man
and they were both gangbangers and one
thing about white boy cholo was like
when you see a white boy join a gang and
when you see a white guy like someone
like you and you're hanging around with
nothing but Mexicans they're white white
guys are the most craziest gangsters
when they were in a Mexican gang they do
stuff that a Mexican man will never
think of like I remember this one white
guy snowman he was a blood he said man
let's go do a home invasion and then
everybody was asking him where he goes
my mom house oh he wanted a home game
all right
and he wasn't there he wanted to I
brought all the homies to rob his house
because he want his mom and dad to get
robbed
why cuz I don't know man they're
probably saying stop hanging out with
all those Mexicans probably man's idea
know like dang so they probably behaved
that way because they they felt no
matter what they they had to constantly
prove constantly men because technically
they could just get a haircut or
whatever put away the flannel and just
slip slip away slip away down at the
Grove
slip away become a social worker and
that'll be it so how long were you in
this gang for and did you ever get
beaten out no I was in this gang to I'm
when I'm for the great boat when I bet
that guy's ear off I went to rehab my
father Greg Boyle took me to rehab and I
disappeared for I'm still gone I never
went back
oh you never went back oh yeah when you
get beaten out of a gang how how long is
that beat them as long as they want to I
know we had a guy in the podcast named
Fabian who was in a gang and he talked
about he got beat up beat out he got
jumped out and he said that when he got
jumped it just last longer but I'm his
uncle
it's doing the gang it's like a simple
expression his uncle is doing a gang so
his uncle over saw him getting jumped
out so he didn't get hurt that bad I
don't have an uncle I probably wouldn't
got killed if I woulda got jumped out
with him when I was 20 but now the white
version of that is our dad's the judge
so we don't go to jail although whatever
the [ __ ] we just did your version is you
got an uncle that overseas being jumped
out yeah I got to tell you dude I'm
learning all kinds of stuff I went on I
don't know YK somebody's just walking by
somebody's recorder it's always feels
weird to have to like read hype
something so you're special on HBO you
shot yourself learning all of your
do-it-yourself stuff from [ __ ] going
around all those warehouses making
pillows out of nothing you ended up
shooting this at the The Improv in San
Jose which is one of my favorite clinic
great Club you feel like you're doing a
theater you know even though it's a club
it's tremendous and you shot it there
it's gonna be on HBO September 30th at
10:00 o'clock called translate this now
I you I know you're a great joke writer
but you I saw an Irish your fears you
told that the told the amazing story
that you touched on today is just stand
up style on this more joke telling more
storytelling or both you know what my my
comedy special is it's more about um
it's more about how I got to this
country with my parents and being a
single father and being a cheater but
yeah I cheat a lot I get caught cheating
cheating all the time I'm bad I can't
help it
I love women I talk about getting caught
cheating cuz I was caught cheating you
know um
Bert both girls showed up to my house oh
god you know I mean yeah in a man it was
crazy and they asked me we're gonna say
for yourself how's it made
how long was that beatdown was that 18
seconds it was crazy
they showed up in the same bar was it
you all they talked to each other yeah
man well now they film it and [ __ ] then
you go in there and then you got to do
like an apology and all
the first 48 yeah Wow
okay so you're gonna do it I can't wait
to see this but I'll miss you okay I
really honestly do as a stand-up
comedian I cannot wait to see this think
you're one of the most interesting dudes
how are you so [ __ ] happy go-lucky I
don't get it I don't know imagine love
life you know I'm never I'm never gonna
go back to that type of lifestyle that I
had in my 20s and I just love living
life man and I'm not gonna say that I'm
perfect because I did fall off the I was
right after I went to rehab I was sober
for 11 years like I didn't charge no
drugs I don't trust no alcohol no beer
nothing but I'm along the way you know
that the more that this kind of comedy
the more you know I did it I'm not going
nowhere I went back to smoking crack he
went right back to crack mm-hmm so you
never really were a booze guy huh no
it's probably gonna boost my man's
Gotti's they do it's like Ralphie May
retweeted my tweet the other night and I
don't understand what he meant at first
because I was in Houston and he
retweeted watch out for those spoons bro
and I like what the hell is rough we
were talking about them spoons then I
said oh [ __ ] bird I got so it's poked
out in Houston Texas
i I all they known for that yeah I
couldn't do no more coke to my nose were
bleeding so I wanted to rock it up and
smoke it in crack instead you know
because I wanted so you're just like I'm
just gonna snort a couple of lines yeah
what did you anticipate like you like
[ __ ] this when I go to Houston I'm gonna
party or it was was it just a
spontaneous thing and all of a sudden
you just said [ __ ] it
oh man just I was over there working the
laughs stop in Houston shout-out to Pete
always booking me Pete and I'm from the
laptop I got I started party man I
started partying and I couldn't find no
powder no coke
so I hope you don't mind me telling this
but I called Joe Diaz I say Joe deal you
know anybody over here you called me at
6:00 in the morning [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I know somebody
so I I knew he knew somebody he goes
talk to this comedian so I spoke to his
comedian and then I'm this little
Mexican food showed up all week taking
care of me I give him free tickets every
day I thank you and I I don't know what
happened man but I I did too much coke
and then I felt like I can't do no more
go through my nose you know starting to
go bad I want to smoke crack now you
know what I mean
I don't want steak I want burgers now
dude a reoccurring story with you is I
don't know what happened last time you
didn't know what happened you were
whipping somebody with a belt now you
don't know what happened there's like a
[ __ ] hole in your nose Jesus well how
long ago was this they told them 2006
all right see ok 2007 so you broke your
record you've gone you've got 11 11 yeah
yeah I called up room service to the one
it's more cracked and I caught a company
or a collar room service and it's a room
service I'm gonna need I'm a big spoon
and a baking soda brought over right now
and they did not bring that to the room
oh they brought it man they did two guys
brought it the governor front dead he
knew me cuz I made friends with him
already know from previous times and he
brought it you know like a big spoon and
he brought Arm and Hammer baking soda
and the guy with him he just was with
him to laugh at me I guess he goes hey I
guess you couldn't believe it you know
this guy just order baking soda and
spoon no way let's go see so the Pope
open the door like they hella gear to me
and they both laugh but yeah man I
wanted to smoke crack okay so and and
then and then how long were you off the
wagon for from when okay so you're sober
for 11 years you go to Houston
you order a spoon and some baking soda
now you snort coke now you're smoking I
got you partied that weekend did you
just come back and go what the [ __ ] was
that and were you able to
to go rehab no man I continue party man
from that moment on and the girl out
with with man she in there being a
hermaphrodite but that was another story
for another time you know but yeah she
was a hermaphrodite she was born with a
penis in a vagina right so like how long
was she your girlfriend before you
figure that out well we were part about
three months you must be a gentleman I
didn't want to touch her or nothing
because she's brown freak old man I
can't be that guy so I just kissed her a
couple of times but then by the third
night you know we were out for three
nights to raid her and I but when I
finally found out I was like whoa man
yeah that's a big skin tag you got there
so is that enough
so was that enough to get you sober
again no man I think it's over again to
to you know that stop sign all right so
now we're still going I think it over to
2009 oh [ __ ] I was and you were already
doing so during those parents you were
still doing stand-up and you weren't you
yeah we're doing stand-up I wouldn't
even know I even now got to go to
Montreal Comedy Festival in 2005 and I
was bad I did the young comedian show
and I did well I guess I did well I got
a little a little print on The Hollywood
Reporter I got an agent UTA is actually
they didn't have any idea you were high
no man I was on I was smoking crack in
Montreal - I hooked it up I mean I found
crack in Montreal it's funny I I saw a
Mexican guy in Montreal and I knew he
spoke Spanish and I told him man how did
you tell I just could tell man here at
the boots you know yet that looked like
I need a job you know you know that
means it's hilarious he got the boots
you know he had that look like okay I
just got here cross-country so he spoke
Spanish he spoke Spanish no English but
he know he knows how to speak French now
but with a Mexican you know Mexican
accent he's doing all the romantic
languages
little double-walled uh any kids back
romance languages yeah man Krag well all
right dude URI I could talk to you for
like [ __ ] ten hours and you just
don't run out it's amazing man I don't
know thank god you're still here I'm
sober no I know but all this stuff
you've done you know like realistically
you probably could have died in 80% of
the stories you just man I'm little
alive yeah I am two men cuz I think
you're a [ __ ] amazing
comedian and person I'm psyched that
you're on a y'all thinks comedy podcasts
network with the what's up fool podcast
I wish you nothing but the best with
your your stand-up special HBO Saturday
September 30th set your DVRs whatever
the kids do now your cord cutters
whatever you do to [ __ ] see this thing
and more success to you and stay out of
Houston I will war so boo all right
thanks Felipe thanks bill burr Billy
Berg all right that was Felipe Esparza
man that [ __ ] guy who's amazing
please check out a special I just said
all that [ __ ] I got to do my reads here
and then I'm going to talk a little NFL
football maybe answer a couple of
questions fill out the rest of this hour
here all right our first oh Jesus look
who's back it's all zip growed up talk
about the challenge of finding I'm not
doing that with zip recruiter you can
post your job to 100 100 plus job sites
with just one click then they're
powerful technology efficiently matches
the right people to your job better than
anyone else that is why that is why
that's why is it cooter is different
unlike any other site zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them in fact 80% of employees
who post jobs on zip get a quality
candidate through the site within one
day no more juggling emails you don't
have time for that [ __ ] or calls to your
office simply screen rate manage
candidates all in one place that zip
recruit is easy to use dashboard find
out today why zip has been used by
businesses of all sizes to
the most quality job candidates with
immediate results and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right free just go to
zip recruited comm / / that zip
recruiter comm / burg one more time for
free go to zip cruda dot-com / / alright
MVM tea also known as movement the
company that started what was started by
two broke college kids that wanted to
wear stylish watches but couldn't afford
them they had no money and somehow they
started a watch company so they started
their own watch company how is this like
how you started well I didn't have any
money tonight then I started a comedy
club
I built my career now [ __ ] it look I got
to come up with like a metaphor here
movement watches start at just $95 at a
department store you're looking at four
to five hundred bucks and that's why
people steal no more shoplifting or
boosting whatever your people call you
it movement figured out that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup providing
the best possible experience over 1
million watch is sold in over 160
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement watches calm that's MVM
t-dot-com / / this watch has a really
clean design seriously I've been getting
compliments and not just on my eyes
they're talking about the watch now is
the time to step up your watch game go
to MVM t-dot-com / / join the movement
and lastly but certainly not least e
stamps calm the cornerstone of this
podcasts advertisement avoid the hassle
man of the post office and mail
everything from postcards to envelope to
packages domestic or international
create your stamps account in just
minutes online with no equipment to
lease and no long term commitments click
print mail and you're done unlike the
post office stamps calm never closes
print postage for lettuce or packages at
your convenience 24/7
/ descriptors I guess I'm supposed to
say this it's convenient it's easy its
reliable it's flexible right just like
your side piece there sorry I use stamps
calm because I always whenever I sell
posters at the end of my show when I
want to go out there and shake sweaty
hands you know and I need to send out my
posters I use stamps calm and I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure it out so can you
and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bird that stamps
comm enter bird one more time Hey
stamps.com never go to the post office
again alright that's it okay stomach is
growling here I'm still on my [ __ ]
diet Oh Billie diet some [ __ ] [ __ ]
sent me a tweet going like you are
obsessed with your [ __ ] weight you
look fine get help it's like dude that's
why I look fine you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't give a [ __ ] your potato skins
eaten fat [ __ ] these guys with your
thick [ __ ] torsos you don't I mean
making that noise when you reach back to
get the seat belt trying to pull it
around you running out of material I
don't want to be that guy you know what
I mean that guy who gets killed by his
airbag because his fat face is too close
to the geeks miniature explosion anyways
all things comedy festival by the way
podcast festival October twenty six
twenty seven twenty eighth twenty ninth
in Phoenix ticket links at billboard.com
by the way I am going to do my first
ever live Monday morning podcast there
at this stand-up live comedy club I'm
gonna do it live and I'll do it live and
I'm gonna do it just how I do it my
[ __ ] house alright I thought about
getting a guest and I was like [ __ ] dad
that's not the jam of what it is that I
do so I'm just gonna do it I don't know
what I'll lay down on the stage I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do but I'm
gonna do it the exact way I do so if you
ever wanted to see this [ __ ] live this
absolute train wreck if you wanted to
see what it looked like in real time
come on down to the stand-up live comedy
club in Phoenix Arizona October 28th I
will be there I don't know when tickets
going
I guess they're on sales now their own
ticket links are at billboard.com there
you go alright anyways let's talk some
NFL football what baby
did you guys enjoy it did your team when
my team won the New England Patriots who
everybody said was gonna go undefeated
and then we lost to the Kansas City
Chiefs and then everybody said oh wait a
minute wait a minute I think Tom Brady
is old now
I think he's washed up I think the
Kansas City Chiefs are gonna win their
first Super Bowl since 1970 that's what
everybody said because the Kansas City
Chiefs beat the New England Patriots
in September now all of a sudden they
can see January how [ __ ] crazy is
that how many [ __ ] times how many
times you're gonna watch the Giants go
Owen - when Owen three and just start
writing them off you saw the points they
scored huh you think they're not gonna
come back and beat Philly they're not
gonna come back and beat Dallas later on
this [ __ ] year when they all get on
the same page they were protecting Eli
much better according to the 30 seconds
of highlights that I saw I'm sticking by
my prediction New England Patriots New
York Giants Super Bowl rematch alright
until the Kansas City Chiefs who I
actually like until who Andy Reid
who I'm not saying he's fat until those
[ __ ] do something in January all
right I think all you need to sit down a
little bit and [ __ ] relax with all
your [ __ ] talking how many [ __ ] guys
have you seen throw for 500 yards in the
regular season and get bounced out in
the first round of the playoffs how many
times did you see a [ __ ] guys
zigzagging all over the field you can't
tackle him and come playoff time he's
sitting on a [ __ ] exercise bike where
an attented windshield across his eyes
huh the incredible lack of [ __ ]
respect that you gave our little
quarterback that could Tom Brady how
dare you how dare you write off the New
England Patriots after one [ __ ] week
huh it's all wishful thinking we're
coming again and we're gonna take your
hearts out and we're gonna pull them out
of your chest we're gonna show them to
you and then we're gonna under inflate
him on our way to another [ __ ]
actually we never got caught
they just suggested that we did it and
got left out of court and then do what I
really need to address the stupid
controversy of the [ __ ] people taking
a knee during the national anthem you
know watching all these white people
getting [ __ ] upset by that like it
real does it really affect your [ __ ]
life and all these [ __ ] idiots trying
to make the point of what they're doing
it's not about your point the people who
started this thing it's about my point
it's about the way that I see it you
know I had a buddy of mine go he's
[ __ ] guys and make a million dollars
you know he think it's bad here why
don't you go [ __ ] move to Syria it's
like why do they have to move why can't
they just live here the way you do I
don't understand that and but Donald
Trump is a [ __ ] genius that he has
everybody talking about this issue cuz
he is trying to get everybody to stop
focusing on the pool party he had with
[ __ ] Vladimir what's-his-face over
there in Russia he doesn't want you
watching that he goes oh look at this
over here
right he goes down to Alabama he gets
all them [ __ ] people all riled up and
he keeps talking about this fatty over
in [ __ ] North Korea that's what he's
doing it reminds me of when oh [ __ ]
Slick Willy
you know bomb that country cuz he stuck
his cigar in that woman's nether region
this is the type of sick people that
become president this is what they do
all right they get caught doing some
fucked-up [ __ ] and then I will say this
about Trump least he didn't go bomb some
people unlike what's-his-face with his
[ __ ] hands who now gets treated like a
[ __ ] hero
I don't understand that guy at all you
know what I mean oh that's great yeah I
got caught getting my dick sucked in the
Oval Office so I bombed the country I
might have killed the baby but I sleep
like whatever not um I know I'm a
conspiracy theorist I [ __ ] hate them
all did you see that thing what's his
face and [ __ ] Korea considered that
we declared war on him right so uh
Maggie maggin Hall whatever [ __ ] name
is Maggie Gyllenhaal what is if what is
the [ __ ] the poor woman who has to go
out and [ __ ] give the press
conferences now because that dude with
no neck
you know who kind of looks like the
political version of Roger Goodell went
out there and [ __ ] it all up the
hell's her name she's got a classic
political name I don't know what the
hell it is she said the fact that North
Korea thinks that we're at war with them
is absolutely preposterous or something
like that and then like a week before
what's-his-face
Trump basically tweeted that that fatty
over there wasn't long for this earth
it's like he kind of just said he's not
gonna last he's not gonna be around long
that's what he said yeah I mean I would
take that as a threat I'll have a -
first have a - you know what they really
need to do they both need to just go to
a [ __ ] house together and [ __ ] grow
up you know bang a couple of [ __ ] they
need to do with threesome right
one of them's getting blown the others
hitting it doggystyle and just their
eyes meet they just start laughing being
like this is a great life right you got
a personal chef - yeah it's [ __ ]
amazing you live in a castle live in a
white house MA it's [ __ ] it's cool
they should just talk about you know
trade stories the way comedians trade
stories about bombing they could just
talk about [ __ ] bomb in other
countries and I don't know what fishing
whatever whatever people at that level
talk about all right let's get to the
questions for this week so I don't have
any [ __ ] problem with these these
guys taking a knee I try to listen to
what it's about rather than getting
wrapped up in what what what it means to
me pharmacists writing in dear Billy bag
chaser I don't know what that means by
the way people thirty-nine days sober
thirty-nine [ __ ] days and this is
this is how well I'm doing with my
sobriety when I flew to Canada I went by
this duty-free and there's this McCallum
rare cast they got this new one black
oak or some [ __ ] like that I was like
I'm gonna buy that okay I'm not gonna
take it to [ __ ] Canada then suck it
down like a [ __ ] jackass I'm just
gonna have this thing waiting for me you
know what I mean
for whenever I fall off the wagon so
this is like what I was thinking the
whole ride in and like you know I'm
getting off the plane I'm trying to beat
the crowd to get over to the taxi line
cuz I don't [ __ ] Hoover and I never
remember to set up a car so I always go
to the [ __ ] taxi line what's great at
LAX is is never anybody there
cuz nobody [ __ ] takes a taxi Avery's
got a friend to pick him up I don't know
what the [ __ ] they do there's always
plenty of cabs so I don't even try to be
first in line at the capstan I go out of
my way over to this duty-free place and
I grab this [ __ ] thing you know and I
just like bring it up to the counter and
the lady goes oh my god she goes [ __ ]
what a wonderful choice and bla bla bla
bla bla you have great taste like I am I
go I'm on the wagon when I come off this
is the bottle I'm opening up she goes
are you going to Canada I said nope I'm
going home and she goes oh I'm sorry I
can't sell you this and like why not she
goes you have to be going to can is
something about the duty-free and I'm
like it's it's legal though do they sell
this anywhere else in the airport if
you're just going back to your home
they're like no no we don't so I don't
know so I had a [ __ ] hissy fit I had
a [ __ ] hissy fit I had two hissy fits
one of the way they're going through
Canadian customs when they made me take
the Deline green plastic cover off of my
[ __ ] laptop like I somehow had a bomb
in there or some sort of bomb residue
and I'm literally taking it off going
I'm gonna crack this thing and they go
well just try to take it off easily it's
like would you look I look like [ __ ]
Howdy Doody what I'm in this matrix I
like what's going on tell me what you
want me to do the [ __ ] so they make me
take that [ __ ] thing off ended up
cracking the cover so I'm are in a bad
mood so rather than you know growing up
and realizing that these [ __ ] people
that was it that the TCA TCP whatever
[ __ ] it took care to yeah what is it
called TSA the [ __ ] TSA rather than
just realizing these people are trying
to protect me which I don't think
they're trying to do I think they're
trying to make it as inconvenient as
[ __ ] possible so I'll agree to have
my [ __ ] retina scan so they can share
that [ __ ] information and gradually
build a [ __ ] robot sorry
put this [ __ ] headphones back um yeah
so all I wanted was a bottle of booze
that's all I wanted and they wouldn't
sell it to me they wouldn't sell it to
me so I went online off I'll figure out
a [ __ ] place to get it alright let's
let's do the little right in here
pharmacist writing in dear Billy bag
chaser your rant on pharmacist last week
was hilarious we have to be able to able
to laugh at ourselves right I just
wanted to weigh in on a couple of things
first off the medication you were
prescribed the anti-inflammatory drug
you received was in the non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug class how the
[ __ ] do you know you didn't even look at
it maybe you just know that I could tell
just by the way he's talking about it I
understand
basically these drugs decrease the
formation of prostaglandins and
thromboxane those chemicals are involved
in the inflammation process which itself
causes pain so these drugs can't just
decrease inflammation without also
decreasing pain thus being labeled a
painkiller okay NSAIDs are not in the
opioid family okay are not happy for
habit-forming I don't know what this
guy's talking about but it sounds like
he's blowing my argument out of the
water however they can be very dangerous
in susceptible populations why can't
just say with addicts susceptible
populations you guys are such [ __ ]
creeps in that world NSAIDs NSAIDs and
SEDs increase the risk of cardiac events
kidney damage and stomach ulcers also I
recovered addicts usually in the elderly
or those with pre-existing conditions
I'm not sure what the other drug you
receive was if it was a narcotic opioid
painkiller and the doctrine pharmacists
did not discuss it with you they would
be now negligible on their parts since
when since when I want to know now that
the the [ __ ] heroin epidemic is
completely out of control in the state
of Ohio is suing pharmaceutical
companies I guarantee I graduated four
years ago and the dangers of narcotics
was extremely stressed
now all the medical bodies are
communicating the dangers of narcotics
to practitioners and overseeing that
prescribing is done appropriately and
maybe this is just a [ __ ] it's just
how we are you know like when we first
they first had that DDT and they sprayed
it all over the place and this is like
great we just ended all these plagues
and then we did all this damage to the
environment we created this [ __ ]
window that is starting to close I feel
or it was this Golden Age of not having
to walk around with the [ __ ] boil on
your face and dying of the Black Plague
and we just got a little out of control
that which would have been great is if
as we eradicated all of these different
diseases if we somehow didn't grow the
population I feel like that's the sweet
spot I feel like that's what the [ __ ]
Illuminati
should be discussing is like what is the
optimal number of people including
ourselves of course who should be
allowed to survive while we keep all the
modern day technologies so we can still
live this awesome flat screen life with
no plagues but like we also can still
sustain like living on this [ __ ]
planet what is that thing what is what
is that number and they're not taking
college because they're a [ __ ] closed
entity all right let me read a few more
of these Wow how much time are we up to
at this point 18 minutes plus 37 is 55
okay all right so here we go gold
money.com
dear Billy copper nuts I heard you talk
about gold money.com
on your pot Monday morning podcast
whoever emailed you about it didn't
explain it very well I feel like all
these are just like free commercials I
haven't put any money into it yet but
now I'm gonna speak about it as an
authority but I am considering it as it
seems pretty legit if you listen to
Rogen's podcast with Peter Schiff he
explains it pretty well and makes a good
pitch yeah but that guy stands to profit
off it granted Schiff admits that he
invested money in the company yes so
he's out he's out I want an independent
[ __ ] debtor I can even find that
anymore evidently they sell you the gold
at a low market price half of 1% I think
what do you mean half of 1% of what
that's just sort of a number floating
out there right stored for you in a
vault of your choosing with your name on
it if you want it they will actually
mail your gold to you for free
minimum of like five grams or something
you also get a MasterCard debit card
that you can use to spend your gold
slash money evidently you can use you
can even get a debit card that is made
of real gold which sounds [ __ ] baller
the Federal Reserve and powers that may
be may never let it work but it seems
like a great idea at least thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself yeah there's a bunch of
great ideas yeah I'm all set on that hey
you give me your cash and we'll put it
in gold in a vault that you choose
that's not where you can see it
all right dating in Saudi Arabia now
maybe I don't know it sounds like even
if their their mind is in the right
place it's gonna go belly-up and then
they're all gonna write themselves
bonuses off your gold that's what I
would guess would happen or the Federal
Reserve will come and say this is all
illegal and take all the gold and then
act like it's in Fort Knox when it's
really [ __ ] I don't know I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is somewhere in the
Hamptons
all right dating in Saudi Arabia hey
there Billy Billy the pie maker hope
you're having a great day anyways I
wanted your advice on this problematic
[ __ ] that I'm stuck in I met this lady
through a common friend of ours Oh God
we talked this is nothing's gonna get
messy when you break up with her then
you're gonna lose her and a friend
we talked she's really cool person we
got a lot of things in common then we
met again twice as a friend and now I
want to ask her out but here's the thing
she is Egyptian and I'm Indian and we
live in Saudi Arabia
Rabia and dating is illegal here well
then what the [ __ ] did you go out with
there for now your hearts gonna get
caused you to get you [ __ ] what do
they do if they beat your feet in the
square they're gonna [ __ ] slap your
dick around in public or something
whatever the punishment is over there I
mean the authority could deport you
immediately or worse send you to jail
for years now I really like this girl
more than you freedom
all right now I really like this girl
and I like you not even love this girl
and I've already thought of of names for
our kids before she even said yes to me
but I'm really stuck on thinking through
my brain okay this is second language
yeah I'm gonna try to help this out here
but I'm really stuck here what shiz
think through my brain or through my
dick should I help well do none of that
is your heart so you should just leave
should I ask her out and open for a
whole nother level of problems or said I
just shut the [ __ ] up any advice from
you is highly appreciated love the
podcast and love you as a brother go
[ __ ] yourself there's not a woman or a
man out there worth going to [ __ ]
prison
in Saudi Arabia I know how bad the
prisons are over here I don't know what
they're like over there you guys got a
lot of oil money although I did running
into this guy from Saudi Arabian who's
laughing his ass off for me go dude we
don't we don't all have oil money and I
was a sec alright fair enough there's
oil men over here I don't have any that
money yeah do it I would walk away from
this [ __ ] it's [ __ ] illegal you could
go to jail you get deported you know
what I mean and even if you love
somebody they're gonna annoy the [ __ ]
out of you so I mean is that worth going
to jail for you know I don't mean is it
illegal to just bang her but then if you
love her I don't know I don't know I I
would I would get out of that I get out
of it alright alright great movie scene
unknown actor all right oh yeah I was
talking about this is the this is a new
topic here where I was talking about
actors that you saw just do like five
lines in a [ __ ] movie and they
absolutely destroyed it and you and your
friends still quote them you don't even
know their [ __ ] names I brought up
that guy last week the guy from pulp
reservoir dogs' the guy in you know when
Tim Roth's character is uh what is he
he's in the [ __ ] bathroom that cops
telling that story I said buddy I am
gonna shoot you in the face you know put
your [ __ ] hands in a - but love that
guy so here he goes one of my favorite
scenes with an unknown actor was kill
bill to bills brother bud I wish I need
to see these movies to do this justice I
mean I saw this but I don't remember it
she she wore the same outfit
that [ __ ] yellow outfit both movies
did she bills brother bud is working as
a bouncer at a rundown strip club he
shows up late for work gets called into
his boss's office his boss Larry Gomez
is played by actor Larry Bishop and he
looks like half a wolf man after doing a
line of blow with a haggard looking
stripper oh I vaguely remember this he
levels his gaze at buzz and bud and says
I don't know what carwash you worked
before you came here that let you stroll
in 20 minutes late
but it wasn't owned by you but it wasn't
owned by me and I own a [ __ ] carwash
I just butchered that line people I
can't read I realized that I need
glasses and I have slight dyslexia like
I was trying to write squawk today and I
knew all the letters I just could not
remember so I was trying to remember
what squawking 7700 versus 7500 I always
get those two mixed up if that's an
emergency landing or a [ __ ] hijacking
I was because one stay alive and the
other is [ __ ] go to heaven all right
sorry that's how you remember it 75 stay
alive 77 go to heaven all right 75 is
hijacking 77 is emergency and 76 need a
fix means your [ __ ] radios out this
doesn't mean anything to you guys I
don't know what carwash you work before
you came here that let you stroll in 20
minutes late but it wasn't owned by me
and I own a [ __ ] carwash there you go
that was a good [ __ ] read that makes
me want to go see that movie he said he
then proceeded to give this world-class
assassin a humiliating dress down
telling him he's as useless as an
[ __ ] on his elbow and crossing off
all his scheduled work days on the
calendar he finishes by telling him
never to wear his cowboy hat to work and
has him cleaned a clogged toilet on his
way out all bud can do is stand there
and take it I hope you've seen this
great movie if not it's worth to watch
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself I'm gonna go
watch it again all right I think i'ma
think this bit is gonna make people go
see these cool movies again and it's
also gonna make everybody laugh at how
bad I can't [ __ ] read out loud all
right bill my favorite line in a comedy
ever it might be from Blazing Saddles
delivered by slim pick
he rides into the scene where his
workers are singing camp is it camptown
races I was always camp camptown races
and says what in the wide wide world a
sport is going on here
I heard you people to try to get I had
you people to try to get a little track
laid not to jump around like a bunch of
Kansas City [ __ ] I remember that line
whatever the hell that means and I'm
quoting a movie by the way before
everybody gets all [ __ ] uptight about
that you know Richard Pryor wrote on
that and he was actually supposed to be
the lead in it and then they went with
the the other actor and I don't know any
actors names okay three number three
bill you asked for movie lines said by
an on movie star actress that your
listeners friends talked about for my
group of friends it's a line from
ghostbusters when Peter Venkman
Bill Murray shows up to Dana's W Weaver
apartment right after the dog monster
runs loose from Lewis tell you I've
never seen that movie I've never seen
Ghostbusters just not a sci-fi guy
thankfully is that considered sci-fi
Venkman shows up to the scene and asks a
cop what happened and the cop
nonchalantly replies some [ __ ] brought
a cougar to a party and it went berserk
[Laughter]
my friends and I have been quoting that
cop for years check it out at 2:30 of
the following oh I can I can look at
these [ __ ] I can click on the links this
is even better why have me read it when
I can click on the links all right we'll
compare my read Jesus Christ what the
[ __ ] kind of link he is sending me here
I thought that was gonna go to your
[ __ ] yeah boy oh boy am I gonna have
to have an apology video here what the
[ __ ] just happened
let's do I do this other one this is
Mike all right [ __ ] all these things
these things are gonna be too long and
evidently they have the n-word in them
yeah boy do I need to take a knee after
this one all right number four I have
two unknown and unheralded actors with
memorable movie lines both are the great
Mel Brooks movies the first one is the
Roman soldier in the history of the
world part one the Empress is
approaching but the there's a horse and
a carriage in the way the Roman soldier
looks directly at the camera and says
move that miserable piece of [ __ ]
the over the top way delivers the line
comes out of nowhere I say it all the
time and then the best impression I can
do you know what I got to do I have to
get the actual clips for this to work
because what I'm now doing is ruining
I'm ruining great movies all right
girlfriend believes in ghosts all right
girlfriend believes in ghosts dear
Grandmaster B I met this lady a few
weeks ago things went really good she's
very cool I found her good-looking and
we have a lot of stuff to talk about I
didn't have a great a lot of I didn't
have a lot of relationships in the past
I'm 32 and I picked up my game about
four years ago everything was great
until we went to a restaurant one day
and she told me she believes in ghosts
not just that she said she actually sees
them and even got patients who come to
her for treatment about it I tried to be
open-minded about it oh my god I can
just hear the silverware hitting the
plates at this point trying to compare
it to people who believe in God but her
believing and this keeps bugging me I'm
not saying she's crazy or wrong Who am I
to know but she doesn't sit right the
way I see the world well then [ __ ]
drop her this is the thing now this is
whole [ __ ] straight across the board
you have to look at everything like all
the leaves are brown and the sky is gray
like if you're dating and somebody does
something and it makes your buddy you
just body literally go like what the
[ __ ] and then you're literally you're
gonna fight that feeling and go well
maybe I need to stop being so Ghost of
phobic it's
no it's [ __ ] ghosts it's weird you
know you're gonna [ __ ] live with
Whoopi Goldberg's character from ghost
that's what you're gonna do people
trying to sit on her and [ __ ] trying to
sit on your wife that's what you're
gonna sign up for me if that's what
you're into by all means do it but if
you're on a date and that there's like
that's a major [ __ ] thing because
it's not like she just believes in and
every once in a while she's gonna hear
like a thump in the house and start
telling you it's a ghost when you're
like honey it's [ __ ] air in the pipes
all right we just have to [ __ ] turn
on the faucet you know in a you know
remember the plumber did work today and
they shut it off for a second that
that's what that is you know that's not
that she actually she's gonna become
like a ghost hunter and all of that
stuff and gradually she's gonna get
starts dressing more and more like she
can predict the future and you don't
want to [ __ ] that you know what I mean
when they start wearing those long
flowing things you know just you just so
many layers of clothes to try to pick up
to just get it going you know you start
wearing like curtains and [ __ ] you don't
need that anyways all right um
sorry that whole [ __ ] movie thing
just I don't know can you guys just send
me the goddamn clip I guess you sent me
the clip what I should have done was
queue it up I tried to do too many
things I tried to promote [ __ ] I try to
do all that and then do the whole thing
the whole [ __ ] thing just fell apart
alright let me just finish with this
last thing a buddy of mine is opening a
[ __ ] a new comedy club on the Upper
West Side in Manhattan
ok Friday October 6 and October 7th it's
like a little 100-seat [ __ ] Club I'm
gonna be coming to town in November and
I'm gonna pop in and do a spot I love
little clubs like that let's see here
Russman Eve's gonna be there Greer
Barnes mark Norman John Fisher rod small
Brian Scott McFadden and many more it's
gonna be a great show if you're on the
Upper East Side I'm up Westside sorry
it's on 201 West 75th streets right next
to the Beacon Theater which is also cool
you know what I mean you go in there and
you [ __ ] do your spots and you come
out and you go wow someday I'll be
across the street it's tremendous give
it a shot if you're in town Friday
October 6 in October 7th I got the
hiccup
that's the podcast please check out
Felipe as far as his new stand-up
special what's it called translate this
September 30th on HBO 10:00 p.m. it
feels more like indigestion I have any
meeting today all right go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday